Elle était pas mal celle la
Comment allez-vous ? Moi ça va très bien oui je suis l'homme qui n'en a rien à foutre
Aujourd'hui on va faire une vidéo réaction facile à faire mais elle me tient vraiment à coeur parce que j'ai découvert un nouveau délire qui me fait encore plus rire que la vidéo de Baptiste qui fait un feu dans sa chambre
petite pensée à Baptiste. Y a pas longtemps je me baladais sur twitter comme tout les jours quand j'adore perdre 3h à rien faire sur internet et je suis tombé  sur ça : "Voici mon fils. Whaou
Incroyable non ? Whaou ! Oh Sangoku comme il est mignon ! Dit bonjour Sangohan.
Bonjour tout le monde "
Bonjour tout le monde ! C'est Mickey quoi.
C'est un extrait du seul doublage québécois
qui a été fait pour DBZ j'crois y a vraiment une très faible proportion de DBZ qui a été doublé en québécois ensuite ils diffusaient
là-bas la VF
Il faut savoir que le doublage des fois c'est compliqué. Ok, donc c'est des boîtes qui se chargent de ça. Ils reçoivent les textes en VO et ils doivent les traduire et parmi ce qu'ils doivent traduire y a des blagues mais des blagues qui marchent par exemple aux Etats Unis qui vont faire marrer les américains mais qui nous vont pas nous faire rire parce qu'on comprend pas le délire donc ils doivent adapter ça
dans notre langue.
Des fois ils se creusent un peu la tête et ils arrivent à faire un truc drôle qui va faire marrer le pays en question.
Mais des fois ils y arrivent pas du tout. On va en voir tout à l'heure des
adaptations nulles. Mais sinon il y a des adaptations fidèles, où juste le doublage, les voix,
collent pas du tout aux persos quoi. Là par exemple c'est terrible quoi, goku on dirait mec, on dirait vraiment une voix off
Goku : "Incroyable non" .
Commençons par terminer cette vidéo là qui est l'une des meilleures : (Goku : "il veut juste te saluer Sangohan") , Sangohan les mecs
ils disent sangohan, c'est génial !
Goku : Regarde quelque chose fonce droit sur nous non
*bruitage*
Tu es né sur la planète "veux jeu ta"
*rires
Sur la planète "veut jeu ta" c'est quoi cette planète mec on la connaît pas c'est un nouvel arc de dbz qui est secret c'est ça et
"Mais quelque chose d'inattendue se produisit."
What !? La voix off qui sort de nulle part !
"Le colossal Saiyan connu sous le nom de Nappa affronta Sangoku en premier." "Le voici
"Oh ! Comme j'ai peur !"
*Gros fou-rire de notre cher Squeezie*
*+ Choqué de ce qui vient de se passer*
Le voici !
Le mec fait 100 fois la taille de Goku et ils lui ont donné la voix de Tchoupi. C'est incroyable.
"C'était maintenant au tour de "Veux jeu ta" le prince de tous les Saiyan." "Montre un peu de quoi tu es fait Kakaro." (?)
"Puissance Kalika !"
*Cri mal reproduit par San Goku*
Y'a pas les...
...Y'a pas les bruitages en fait. Je crois que dans le ".Rar" qu'ils ont reçu il n'y avait pas le dossier bruitages, ils ont
oublié de le mettre au Japon. Du coup c'est terrible quoi. C'est un combat et y a pas de bruitages.
"Maintenant, c'est TON tour !"
*Chargement de Ki*
Ah !! Le bruitage *cri* +MLG
*Ambiance de fête rajoutée au montage ! Allez !!*
Wow ! "Qu'es-tu donc ?" "Je suis l'espoir de l'univers."
*Stop de musique * Je suis la réponse à tout les êt...
*Fou-rire supprimé*
Ils utilisent, non sans déconner, ils utilisent les codes de montage qui font marrer dans les Vine et tout, t'sais, genre : nanana
Salut. Le fait de couper la musique au moment où le gars dit la blague, mais eux ils le font alors qu'il y a un truc
hyper sérieux, faut pas faire ça.
*Second stop de musique* "Je te ferais payer tout le mal que tu as fait" Mais arrêtez de couper la musIQUE !
*Bruit D'orgasme ?*
Ça c'est vraiment le oh ! que tu fais soit aux toilettes soit au lit mais y a pas de... C'est pas la joie ça, hein, c'est l'orgasme.
Ou alors il est très amoureux de Freezer. "C'est ainsi que le garçon connu sous le nom de Sangoku continua de grandir..." en VF !
Woooh !
Quelqu'un nous envoie un extrait de X-men 92 en VF.
*Bruit de beaucoup de missiles*
Oh ! Il y en a beaucoup trop des missiles !
*Encore un rire de Squeezie*
Ah, le mec. C'est sûr c'était après la pause de midi,  qu'il soit allé au japonais
le serveur jap' leur a proposé un petit saké pour digérer, ça a mal tourné. Ah oui ! J'ai vu Batman passer. J'avais vu je
crois que c'était Patrick Guillotin qui doublait Batman et c'est aussi le mec qui double dans les Simpson. Merde j'ai oublié le nom !
"Mais enfin !"
Non je vais pas l'imiter parce que il est inimitable *rires*
Là j'ai faillit faire un truc scandaleux. Ah mince j'ai oublié son nom, mais bref il double un perso des Simpson
et il fait aussi des voix dans les Looney Tunes
"Mais je t'interdis de me dire 'Chut!'
"Je ferais autant de bruit que ça me plaira." 'Fin bref il double des persos vraiment
cartoon et un peu, pas idiot, mais bon voilà, second degré. Et là il se retrouve à doubler un super héros donc tu te doutes bien
que va y avoir un problème.
"Soyons prudents, le Riddler a pu installer des pièges."
*Énième rire*
"Tous ceux qui pénètrent dans le temple de Cucuba doivent être ..." La voix du méchant est bien.
"Batman à l'aide !" "J'arrive Robinnn !"
*Squeezie imite le "Robinnn*
Mec, je veux que tous les héros des films Marvel à venir au cinéma là, avec les budgets de plusieurs centaines de millions, soient doublés
par cet homme. Patrick, tu es notre héros
"AHHhhhhh"
"Nous tombons !"
Le mec dit juste ce qui se passe au cas où le spectateur n'a pas compris qu'ils tombaient. "Voyons voir, l'ordinateur fonctionne comme ça."
*On a perdu Squeezie là ...*
Mais comment c'est possible ?!
D'où le directeur artistique il a pas dit p'tain, on a merdé c'est un super héros et là tout à l'air ridicule y a un problème.
En plus ce qui est terrible c'est que Superman il est bien doublé. Wonder Woman (<3), ça va, la voix off elle est bien. La voix du méchant est bien.
Y'a vraiment que la voix de Batman qui lui va pas du tout donc ça contraste de ouf.
"Quelques minutes plus tard, ils arrivent jusqu'à l’Everest." "On y est Batman et alors ?" Ah ok, je retire ce que je viens de dire
Ils ont fait tous débiles
Oh putain je pourrais mater ça toute la journée. Alors, ah y a aussi ken le survivant qui avait des problèmes mais je crois
d'adaptation c'était pas doublage qui était mauvais ou qui collait pas aux personnes. C'était juste la traduction des textes qui était
fait vraiment sans effort. "Il va utiliser la technique secrète du 'Hokuto de cuisine,
j'espère qu'il sait ce qu'il fait". Du 'ho-ku-to de cuisine' *rires* "L'essence même de l'école 'hokuto à beurre' est de frapper son adversaire."
Ils font que des jeux de mots avec 'hokuto', mec. Normalement c'est
H-O-K-U-T-O et vu qu'il y a couteau ils font couteau de beurre, couteau de cuisine, c'est insupportable ! "L'attaque de la Grande ourse est d'une puissance"
"incalculable. Moi même j'ai des difficultés pour le calculer."
Le roi du hokuto Très aiguisé
Et regarde mec ils font que des jeux de mots. Ils s'arrêtent pas !
...*Inaudible* , ce Hokuto à éplucher...
Mais arrêtez !
Ah !!
"Je serais très bientôt le seul et unique détenteur du savoir Hokuto à huître"
AHHHHHH !
"Il utilise la technique planche à pain."
*rires* Le pire des techniques jamais inventé
"Les oiseaux de feu de l'école Nanto, sont des disciples particuliers qui ont reçu un entraînement spécial." Il parle vraiment comme si c'était un documentaire animalier
c'est incroyable ! "Leurs attaques ont la grâce et la rapidité de l'oiseau de feu. Leur pouvoir d'une force est d'une cruauté sans égal" sans égaaaal.
Après attention il faut pas les blâmer. C'était complètement une autre époque. C'est dans les années
90, la culture nippon n'avait pas encore marquée la France comme c'est le cas actuellement. Et c'était surtout destiné pour les enfants donc ils censuraient
vachement et ils adaptaient de manière un peu
rigolo mais pour les enfants. Mais tu regardes ça maintenant, c'est génial, c'est du bonheur, c'est trop bien. Jaguar Force
Alors qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Oh c'est une scène dramatique en plus. Oh c'est une scène triste, quand ils vont ouvrir la bouche ça va être...
"OKay..."
"Elle est morte, à cause de moi"
"J'aurais voulu que ce soit moi et pas elleee"
"elle m'inspirait"
Mais calmes toi !
"Elle m'aimait". Non mais mec, c'est chaud. "Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi..." Arrêtes tu vas me faire pleurer
*Bruits censés être des pleurs*
"Elle est morte à cause de moi"
*Encore des bruits censés être des pleurs*
Wahou putain ! Trop d'émotion, je vais pleurer bordel. Alors, ah le doublage français des années 90 les meilleurs à jamais, mais oui !
Exactement !
"Oui dépêches-toi je suis vraiment pressé et dis moi ce que tu veux me proposer." "Je vois que tu as toujours aussi mauvais caractère"
"*Nom du perso*"
"Et connaissant ta réputation je pense que tu graviras vite tous les échelons." Tous les échelooons ! C'était vraiment une autre époque c'est ouf.
Ah ! On nous envoie un doublage nul. "Bonjour,  je suis devant un studio d'enregistr..."
"Quoi ?! Non ! Protégez-nous, au secours ! Appelez mon p'tit !"
"Ah je fais une crise d'angoisse !"
"Continuez à lire s'il vous plaît, monsieur le pirate" Mais je la doublais bien cette mouette, OK ! J'y ai mis tout mon cœur !
Continuez à lire s'il vous plaît, monsieur le pirate.
Déjà pour ma défense dans cette vidéo le pire c'est pas mon doublage, ok, c'est ma coupe de cheveux
“Philippe !"
"Je sais où tu te caches"
"Viens ici que je te butes enculé !"
"Ta gueule !"
"Viens ici sale enculé !" "Salaud !" Salaud ! Il a pas de voix c'est génial. Merci pour ce dialogue
incroyable, il m'a fait beaucoup de bien. Oh oui, du Jojo's Bizarre Adventure, alors attends, attends. "Je m'appelle  : Jean-Pierre Polnareff."
C'est ce que je me disais au début quand ils doivent adapter des blagues dans notre langue. Je pense que là par exemple ça en fait
partie
"Oui, tu es beau même dans les pays pauvres."
Il te sort des punchlines mon gars.
Incroyable. "Alors faut pas faire faire aux autres ce que t'as la trouille de faire tout seul, c'est dingue ça t'as vraiment pas de
race."
Le doublage est génial, c'est un best-of des trucs les plus cools en fait du doublage, là, il n'est pas du tout raté.
"Un homme, avec un rêve"
"En fait, je suis un lonbax." "Bon d'accord, un lonbax, avec un rêve."
"C'est vous, que nous voulons." "Aller !" "Si vous êtes courageux, alors vous serez
à la hauteur." "Je m'appelle Ratchet, je crois que je vais t'appeler Clank."
"Plongez dans..." Mais arrêtez de me vanner ! En plus vous me vannez mais le film il a tros bien marché.
*Poin Poin Poin Poinnn*
En tout cas c'était une hyper bonne expérience j'ai adoré faire ça, à l'époque c'était trop cool et après libre aux gens de trouver que
le doublage est bien ou pas mais c'était une bonne expérience. Mais j'ai clairement pas un
millième du talent de tout ce qu'on vient de voir là.
Oh, putain c'est vrai que j'avais fait une vidéo il y a cinq ans où je... Oh non, bon on finit sur ça.
On finit sur ça parce qu'après j'aurai pas le courage de faire l'outro. J'avais fait une vidéo où je faisais tous les bruits du trailer
de MW3 mais avec ma bouche.
Voilà déjà l'idée vous fait pas kiffer, vous avez envie de partir ; " Mais bientôt vous verrez
que chaque son,
chaque voix,
était destiné (à te faire rigoler)
*Masse de bruit fait par Squeezie d'il y a 5 ans*
Je sais que tu te cache ici Cortex
Attention à la base *boom* (+ encore pleins de bruits)
(Squeezie , dégouté de son oeuvre , se barre...)
*Crise d'épilepsie*
Et voilà les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur le doublage, j'espère que ça vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude.
Un immense respect aux doubleurs français parce qu'ils sont vraiment très très bon. On a des voix
incroyable je pense à Patrick Poivey, à
Christophe Lemoine parmi tant d'autres.C'est un travail de malade et même si les français se plaignent très souvent des VF, même dans les jeux
on a vraiment des vrais talents, quoi, des gens très doués qui font ça. Et je comprends qu'on puisse préférer la VO parce que
Bah déjà, c'est la voix de l'acteur quand on parle de films ou de
téléfilms ou de séries.
Forcément tu te rends mieux compte du jeu d'acteur quand c'est en VO que quand c'est en VF mais pour tout ce qui est
dessins animés ou films
d'animation où quoi, je trouve vraiment qu'en France on a de très bons doubleurs et dans ces cas là je trouve ça dommage et faire une fixette
sur la VO alors que les VF sont très très bonnes. Bon sauf quand Squeezie double le perso principal mais sinon... Une petite dernière
la comme ça. J'espère que vous avez passé un bon moment. A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
C'est tout c'est tout
(Abonne-toi a la chaine de squeezie ) sous-titres par Jujuland et corrigé par Vic